[Music]
we all know the scene the Philosopher's
Stone Harry's first time in Gringotts
his first real exposure to the Wizarding
World
where does Hagrid bring him to vault 687
and his massive stack of gold good way
to keep him humble it's like something
out of a pirate movie it's a totally
ridiculous stack of money
Harry's 11 and about to start at
Hogwarts which means that it might be
time to buy school supplies I hope you
can manage now if there's one thing that
I know for sure it's that the Potters
were wealthier than a certain other
family in the series out of wheezes if
there's one thing that I've always
thought was strange is that the Wizards
lived frugally while Harry had an
enormous vault full of gold at Gringotts
which he seemingly never used or needed
he lived at their house half of the time
but I only ever really saw him on the
receiving end of gifts and not often
sharing his immense wealth not only that
but he had a knack for not actually
needing to use his money for anything
his most expensive asset is probably as
Nimbus 2000 and that was a gift from
McGonagall who's on a professor's salary
so that bears the question where did all
this money come from why were his
parents so wealthy how did they leave
him so much
both Lily and James were only 21 years
old when they died and Lily was of
muggle-born parents which means that
this money likely came from James's side
but where did James get it it must have
been family money in a short story
posted on Pottermore it is revealed by
rolling at the PATA family lineage made
their money in potions this started with
a founding patriarch of the Potter
family Linford of Stinchcomb aka the
Potter a Linford was a 12th century
wizard and potion pioneer in the words
of Potter more Linford was a vague and
absent-minded fellow whose muggle
neighbours often called upon his
medicinal services none of them realized
that Linda it's wonderful cures for pox
and egg were magical they all thought
him harmless and loveable old chap
pottering about in his guard
middle his funny plant his reputation as
a well-meaning eccentric served Linford
well for behind closed doors he was able
to continue this series of experiments
that laid the foundation of the pata
family's fortune Linford was responsible
for creating remedies still used to this
day including Skellig ro which
interestingly enough was actually used
on Harry in the Chamber of Secrets the
function of Skellig ro is quite simple
and as is to heal bones it can repair
broken bones or grow back missing bones
entirely it is described as a dreadful
tasting potion when regrowing a bone
have reira marks that it felt like
having large splinters lodged in his arm
another potion that Linford was
responsible for is an early version of
the pepper up potion the pepper up
potion is a cure for the common cold and
helps the recipient to warm up the only
known side effect is that it causes
Stephen to command of the drinkers ears
for hours on end a potion maker called
Glover hip Worth based the pepper up
potion that we know today off of Lynne
Fritz potion there always seems to be
something amiss with his potions even
though they function well probably
something to do with them being so old
the potion was notably used in the
series in February 1995 when it was used
on the hostages of the champions of the
Triwizard Tournament after they came out
of the great lake with the massive
success of these potions the Potter
family lineage continued to follow in
then Fritz footsteps it was then flee
mont Potter harry's grandfather and
James's dad who continued to invent
potions and rake in the cash Fremont's
never met Harry but he did live long
enough to make and leave him enough gold
for a lifetime Fremont took the family
fortune and quadrupled it by creating
the famous sleek Easy's hair potion the
potion was a hair potion and scalp
treatment marketed with the following
slogan two drops tame even the most
bothersome bonnet it was essentially
used for taming unruly hair sleekly and
fashionably styling it used that the
product was cautioned against redheads
as using it may produce unique results
the potion was most notably used by
Hermione when she went to the Yule Ball
with Victor Krum
so with all that in mind I guess that
sort of answers the question Harry's
family lineage were responsible for
creating massively popular potions that
were used for hundreds and hundreds of
years
I wonder if Harry continues to generate
royalties that's all for this video
until next time hurry hurry did you put
on able to cobble to fire Dumbledore
asked calmly
[Music]